[Music]
last year I said that revisiting the
conventions of the Zelda series would be
our theme for the new Zelda game and for
Wii U however before I get into that let
me talk about something that I needed to
help to realize this ambition in fact
it's something that we've wanted to do
for a long time in the Legend of Zelda
series and so development began with
this as our focus in the earlier
releases of The Legend of Zelda games
players got to explore a wide area
scrolling up down left and right however
after the game transition to 3d and the
hardware continued to evolve it became
harder to create that feel of being in a
vast world for example in Wind Waker
we used various techniques to create a
wide world where you could freely
explore many isolated islands it was
very hard to create one large world
where everything felt connected we had
to design small bounded areas with a
defined entrance and exit and putting
them all together made it feel like you
were playing in a large world but you
still couldn't cut through the
boundaries wherever you liked to explore
that world today I'd like to talk to
everyone about the latest Zelda game for
Wii U but first please take a look at
how the game looks on screen this is the
new world of Zelda it's quite a vast
world isn't it you can even reach those
mountains in the distance if you walk
far enough we couldn't create such a
wide world like this in the past as far
as what you can do with such a vast
field to explore as soon as those
boundaries are removed it means you can
enter any area from any
direction so the puzzle solving in this
game begins the moment the player starts
to think about where they want to go how
they will get there and what they will
do when they arrive this is a clean
break from the conventions of past games
that Zelda series where you had to
follow a set path and play through the
scenario in the right order I believe
this departure will create opportunities
for new gameplay that have not been
experienced in previous Elda games as
you can see and as you know from the
Zelda series the world in these games
can be quite peaceful however it is a
Zelda game after all so strong enemies
will certainly appear even in this
setting powerful enemies appearing in
such a peaceful world is one of the
defining features of the Zelda series I
think that one convention we can keep
right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]